[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn willkommen schön dass
Sie dabei sind an diesem Sonntagmittag
das ein chinesisches Staatsunternehmen
in den Hamburger Hafen einsteigen will
wäre vermutlich vor einem Jahr noch
einfach nur eine Meldung in den
Wirtschaftsnachrichten gewesen heute ist
es Stoff für den bisher schärfsten
Konflikt in der Bundesregierung in acht
Monaten Wirtschaftskrieg mit Russland
haben wir alle am eigenen Leib am
eigenen Portemonnaie gespürt was es
bedeutet von einem autokratischen Regime
abhängig zu sein sechs Bundesministerien
und die EU-Kommission sagen nun die
Abhängigkeit von China sei bereits heute
höher und dürfe auf keinen Fall weiter
wachsen Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich
diese Woche über diese Bedenken
hinweggesetzt die Beteiligung soll jetzt
stattfinden wenn auch in etwas geringem
Umfang als geplant unser Thema heute
riskante Geschäfte wie abhängig sind wir
von China Russland und Co und ich freue
mich auf diese Runde marc schiritz ist
wieder bei uns stellvertretender
Ressortleiter Politik bei der Zeit in
Berlin ich begrüße Julia Löhr
wirtschaftskorrespondentin der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung im
hauptstadtbüro herzlich willkommen
Nicole Bastian sie leitet das
auslandsressort beim Handelsblatt und
willkommen zurück Felix Lee
Wirtschaftsredakteur ehemaliger
Chinakohl der Tageszeitung unterli der
den ich als ersten Frage Costco ein
chinesischer Staatskonzern will ein
Terminal am Hamburger Hafen teilweise
kaufen mit Unterstützung des
Kanzleramtes kaum ist das passiert ist
schon in Dortmund eine chip-fabrik auf
der Einkaufsliste was ist das normal
naiv gefährlich
eisenorderlich
gefährlich im Fall des Hafens und das
muss man auch trennen also es geht um
kritische Infrastruktur und es geht um
Unternehmen Privatunternehmen wo die
Unternehmen vielleicht auch selbst
Risiken dann in Kauf nehmen müssen oder
die Chancen ergreifen müssen und dann
gibt es noch den dritten Bereich
Schlüsselindustrien inwiefern die
Politik das auch fördern soll
im Verhältnis den
wirtschaftsverhältnissen zu China warum
ich den Hafen als höchst kritisch
empfindet den an einen chinesische
Staatsunternehmen zu verkaufen oder
Teile davon ist das es geht ja nicht nur
um die
regionalen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil im
Fall jetzt von Hamburg was man daraus
was man daraus gewinnen kann sondern
China verfolgte er eine viel umfassende
Strategie nämlich diese neue
Seidenstraße es geht um Geopolitik China
ist dabei weltweit sich in Häfen
einzukaufen hat einige auch viele einige
in Europa bereits erworben und möchte da
nicht nur die Handelswege kontrollieren
die weltweiten sondern möchte auch
irgendwann geopolitisch beeinfluss
ausüben und das tut es teilweise auch
schon wie wir das im Fall von Litauen
gesehen haben irgendwo Betonieren
Annäherung an Taiwan bemüht hatte und ja
ich will gerade die anderen mit in die
Runde nehmen aber da sie ist ansprechend
vielleicht ein Blick auf eine kurze
Grafik die so ein bisschen das Ausmaß
zeigt weltweit sind es mittlerweile 96
hafenbeteiligungen aber auch in Europa
einige von erheblichen Gewicht in
Seebrücke zum Beispiel 85 Prozent Teile
des Hafens von Piräus bis zu 100%
schieritz der hafendil in Hamburg jetzt
okay normal oder gefährlich also ich
teile die bedenken dass wir es bei China
mit einem Land zu tun haben das
strategische Einfluss ausbauen will in
der Welt ich bin mir noch nicht sicher
ob diese Hafen die das richtige Beispiel
ist und Exempel zu statuieren weil es
wird ja nicht der Hafen verkauft oder
teilweise verkauft der bleibt in Besitz
der Stadt Hamburg wie es seit 800 Jahren
glaube ich ungefähr sondern es geht um
ein spezifisches Terminal und da haben
die Betreibergesellschaft
und wir sprechen jetzt nach der
Intervention der andere Ministerien ja
auch über einen Anteil von unter 25
Prozent das heißt ohne spermienorität
die Chinesen können da nichts aufhalten
und deswegen bin ich mir nicht sicher ob
man da wirklich von der kritischen
Infrastruktur sprechen kann die
kompromittiert wird durch diesen Deal
deswegen würde ich bei diesem Deal sagen
in Ordnung aber nicht zu sagen
Wachsamkeit bleiben lassen aber diese
24,9% sehe ich jetzt erstmals nicht so
problematisch an ja Frau auch der
Hauptgeschäftsführer des die hierk hat
heute morgen im Deutschlandfunk gesagt
dass seine symboldiskussion und für sich
genommen kein Problem ich sehe es
tatsächlich ein bisschen kritischer weil
sie haben es in der Anmoderation
angesprochen die Politik der neuen
Seidenstraße ist ja eine erklärtes Ziel
von China eben zu expandieren und sich
wichtiger Handelsrouten sich dort
Einfluss zu sichern und ich würde schon
sagen dass sich Deutschland quasi mit
dem grünen Licht für diesen Deal zum
Teil dieser Strategie machen lässt und
auch zum Teil einer Politik von
Präsident chichenping der dazu nimmt
aggressiver und autoritärer auftritt und
deswegen ist das aus meiner Sicht
zumindest keine reine Finanzbeteiligung
als die es Scholz jetzt verkauft sondern
wenn ein chinesischer Staatskonzern in
Europa investiert ist das immer auch
eine politische eine strategische
Entscheidung und ich würde ihnen
zustimmen dass das jetzt stand heute im
Herbst 2022 vielleicht nicht so das
Problem ist oder im Winter 2022 wenn der
Deal dann tatsächlich so vollzogen
werden sollte aber es ist natürlich in
dem Moment ein Problem wenn China Taiwan
angreifen sollte und der Westen
Sanktionen gegenüber China verhängt und
dann die spannende Frage ist werden die
auch an helfen umgesetzt wo China sich
Einfluss gesichert hat und was machen
wir wenn nicht Sebastian ihre
Einschätzung zum hafentel ich glaube
auch dass wenn wir auf die Politik mit
Russland schauen und die lernen die wir
daraus gezogen haben der Hafen Deal am
Ende einer Worst Case Betrachtung Stand
haben muss was passiert wenn wir eine
chinesische Aggression in Taiwan haben
deswegen sehe ich ihn auch als kritisch
an ich glaube es geht weniger um Exempel
dass wir statuieren sondern ich glaube
das ist jetzt ein Zeichen dass wir ganz
dringend
Prinzipien brauchen welche unserer
Wirtschaftsbereiche so kritisch sind
dass wir für nicht nur China sondern
autokratische Systeme weltweit die
Schranken hochziehen
danke für Ihre Kommentare im Netz danke
wenn sie im Livestream bei Tagesschau
und presseclub.de dabei sind
Frau Bastian ich sehe Tobias Graham der
fragt warum setzt sich Scholz dann für
einen Teilverkauf der Chinesen ein warum
quasi nur er alleine also wenn das gilt
was Sie gesagt haben welche Argumente
hat er warum macht er das naja eins
seiner Argumente ist das was Marc
schiritz ja schon gesagt habe es geht um
eine Minderheitsbeteiligung der die es
geht nur um ein Terminal im Hafen das es
ist jetzt eben nicht so dass China den
kompletten Hamburger Hafen kontrolliert
es ist aber und darauf hat ja auch zum
Beispiel das Außenministerium noch mal
ganz dezidiert hingewiesen es ist ein
Einfallstor und
die Argumente von von Olaf Scholz sind
die dass es nur eine
Minderheitsbeteiligung sind das
Einfallstor kann er glaube ich nicht
wegdiskutieren und auch der
Verfassungsschutz hat ja bedenken da hat
er ja auch Gründe wir haben es mit einem
massiven Konflikt in der Regierung zu
tun ich habe es eingangs gesagt sechs
Ministerien haben Bedenken das
Außenministerium hat auch das ist
ungewöhnlich eine abweichende Position
zum Kabinettsbeschluss zu Protokoll
gegeben sinngemäß mit der Begründung sie
erweitere den strategischen Einfluss
Chinas auf die deutsche Infrastruktur
unverhältnismäßig
habe ich auch gesehen und gelesen ich
verstehe es trotzdem nicht so richtig
muss ehrlich sagen also ich verstehe das
Argument einfach das Tor sozusagen mein
argumentiert ja die fangen jetzt mit
24,9% an und dann kommen 30 40 50 und
dann irgendwann gehört in der Hafen so
das Argument finde ich ein bisschen so
wie wenn meine Kinder sagt ich will
Süßigkeiten dann gebe ich in eine und
dann natürlich wollen sie mehr aber es
heißt ja nicht dass ich ihn mehr geben
muss also es gibt ja diesen Automatismus
nicht und ich sehe auch wirklich nicht
wie uns China mit diesen 24,9 % in einem
Konfliktfall weh tun können soll also
sagen Angriff auf Taiwan passiert und
dann seit Tina so jetzt was ziehen wir
uns zurück na gut dann verstanden oder
verkaufen sein jemand anderen also ich
sehe diese ich sehe diese Gefahr bei
einem größeren Anteil bei Stimmrecht und
so weiter bei Zugriff auf Daten auf
wirkliche kritische Infrastrukturen aber
ob das hier der Fall ist da bin ich wenn
wir gerade einfach nicht so sicher Frau
löhrli das sagt sich so leicht daher
dann verstaatlichen wir die Halt und
alles wird wieder gut ich meine wir
haben es ja gesehen im Jahr 2015 wurden
die Gasspeicher in Deutschland der große
Speicher in Reden von BASF an Gazprom
verkauft und das ging
fünfeinhalb Jahre so weit gut weil die
Beziehungen zwischen beiden Ländern ja
sie waren jetzt nie wirklich gut aber
sie waren zumindest nicht so angespannt
und just mit der vergangenen Jahres
wurde es eben zu einem Problem und
dieser Gasspeicher wurde nicht wieder
aufgefüllt und im Wirtschaftsministerium
waren recht viele Leute damit
beschäftigt jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass
Gasprom den Einfluss auf diesen Speicher
verliert und er eben wieder aufgefüllt
wird und ich finde nicht dass das jetzt
quasi die Maßgabe sein sollte so wir
lassen es jetzt erstmal laufen und im
Notfall können wir das schon noch
irgendwie reingrätschen
vielleicht sollten wir da doch vorher
gewisse Schranken hochziehen und eben
schon mal den Worst Case mit Bedenken
aber es ist nicht in Unterschied
zwischen Gas sozusagen Zugriff auf
Gasspeicher die ich dann als feindliche
macht wirklich nicht mehr auffüllen kann
und eben dieser Minderheitsbeteiligung
an dem Terminal da diese parallel
schließen sondern um die Frage inwieweit
werden dann in Hamburg Container
abgefertigt oder nicht aber also
man muss ja auch mal betrachten wer
genau da der Investor ist und ich würde
mal sagen wenn es jetzt eine hongkonga
eine Hongkong privat Reederei wäre oder
auch von mir aus vom Festland dann sind
würde ich sagen sind die Bedenken etwas
geringer aber bei cosco handelt es sich
um ein hundertprozentigen Start
Staatsunternehmen besetzt von
Leuten die unmittelbar der KP-Führung
unterstehen oder teilweise Teil dieser
KP-Führung sind und das zu einem
Zeitpunkt wo wir doch auch überlegen und
natürlich geht es da auch um
Symbolpolitik aber das von einem
Zeitpunkt wo wir doch überlegen wo wir
feststellen dass wir in bestimmten
Bereichen viel zu abhängig inzwischen
von China sind und zwar nicht nur im
privatwirtschaftlichen Bereich sondern
zunehmend auch dass wir vom chinesischen
Staat erpressbar sind ist das ja völlig
falsche Signal da jetzt auch
hafenanteile zu verkaufen und wie gesagt
es geht ja beim Hafen das wird da würde
ich das jetzt auch etwas anders sehen
wenn man bei solchen auch minderbeteil
dann hat man natürlich trotzdem
Zugriff auf wichtige Datenstrom nach
Häfen sind ja nicht nur dass da jetzt
Schiffe anlegen und dann ausgeladen
werden sondern das ist ja viel viel mehr
und wenn man sich dann auch diese
Strategien der chinesischen Seite
anguckt die das ja ganz klar formuliert
haben diese welche Punkte man weltweit
zu führenden Handels Macht zu erreichen
haben will erreichen will dann sind das
genau die Punkte wo ich China auch
versucht einzugreifen in Häfen in
Flughäfen in Eisenbahnstrecken und so
weiter und
da kann man sich über die Detail
schreiten die inwiefern da jetzt
unmittelbar beeinfluss schon da ist aber
er ist durchaus gegeben also es gibt da
schon Einfluss bei auch bei einer
minderbeteiligung und ich fürchte dass
das noch mehr werden könnte und wenn man
das ganze Gewebe anguckt das natürlich
dann auch dann unmittelbarer staatlicher
Einfluss von der chinesischen Seite
vorhanden ich versuche mal das Bild zu
weiten ich habe eingangs gesagt was wir
mit Russland in den letzten Monaten
erlebt haben das sehr plastisch und
nachvollziehbar also Gas kann man zwar
nicht sehen aber am Heizkörper fühlen
also wir verstehen alle sehr konkret was
das heißt so ich sag mal eine
Minderheitsbeteiligung von dem Terminal
ist etwas deutlich abstraktes deshalb so
das größere Bild wie abhängig sind wir
denn bereits von China so abhängig wie
von Russland mehr oder weniger na das
ist schwierig zu sagen ich würde da auch
mehrere Ebenen sehen zum einen ist sind
einige der deutschen Unternehmen extrem
abhängig vom chinesischen Markt wir
haben Unternehmen wie Infineon bei den
40% des Gesamtumsatzes vom China
Geschäft abhängt bei den
Automobilherstellern ist ungefähr ein
Drittel das heißt da sind wir natürlich
abhängig aber ein Drittel des Umsatzes
des Umsatzes hängt vom China-Geschäft
bei covestro ist es ungefähr ein Fünftel
also das sind schon veritable
Bestandteile nicht alles davon ist
problematisch und ich finde das ist das
wichtige in dieser Diskussion wir wollen
uns nicht von China abschotten wir
sollen uns auch nicht von China
abschotten sondern wir müssen definieren
welche Bereich wollen wir
und ich mag das Wort abschotten nicht
sondern welche Bereiche wollen wir
schützen und da gehörten neben dem Hafen
neben der Bahn zum Beispiel wenn man
eine Bahn Privatisierung machen würden
würden wir dann chinesischen Investor
reinlassen müssen wir uns vorher
überlegen vor allen Dingen aber auch die
technologische Infrastruktur zu da
gehört das 5g-netz zu wir erinnern uns
an die huawei-debatte die wir hatten ja
und da finde ich müssen wir in
Deutschland Prinzipien haben die müssen
wir aber auch in Europa einigermaßen
übereinander kriegen damit das Ganze
sich zu einer wirklichen Strategie
entwickelt
niemals genau diese Infrastruktur an
ausländische
förderndebatte reinbringen den der
Reziprozität wenn kein deutsches
Unternehmen sich an einem chinesischen
Hafen beteiligen kann warum lassen wir
ein chinesisches Unternehmen in den
deutschen Hafen ich finde auch dieses
Argument das muss in die neue
holistische deutsche
Außenwirtschaftspolitik noch klarer rein
aber ich diesen sozusagen dass das die
Notwendigkeit Wirtschaftspolitik
strategischer zu definieren das würde
ich auf jeden Fall so sehen also wir
kommen ja aus einer Welt in der wir
gesagt haben wir wollen als Deutschland
maximale internationale Arbeitsteilung
ja in cayenne ist zwar ein Porsche aber
kommt aus Bratislava und die
Zubehörteile aus Sri Lanka und sonst
woher und das wollen wir davon
profitieren wir das ist gut für die
ganze Welt das schafft Reichtum und
Wohlstand und das war ja auch so wir
haben auch extrem profitiert und dann
haben wir geglaubt dass diese
Abhängigkeiten sozusagen diese
ökonomischen Abhängigkeiten auch
politische Abhängigkeiten definieren die
dann zu einem Ende der Geschichte wir
werden alle liberale Demokratien jetzt
war es nicht und was wir jetzt ja
feststellen ist dass diese
Abhängigkeiten gegen uns gewendet werden
russland hat es angefangen China kann
der nächste das nächste Land sein
irgendein Land das irgendeinen kleinen
Rohstoff herstellt den vielleicht gar
nicht dessen Name vielleicht gar nicht
kennen der irgendwo im chemischen
Periodensystem ganz weit hinten steht
kann unser Industrie lahmlegen so das
kann natürlich nicht so sein weil diese
diese Welt alle gut und nett miteinander
umgehen die ist vorbei ist seit dem 24
februar und deswegen bin ich auch sagen
wir müssen jetzt strategisch schauen wie
können wir unseren Abhängigkeit
reduzieren wir werden sie aber nicht
wegkriegen also Deutschland als an Land
ohne Rohstoffe und mit einem relativ
kleinen Binnenmarkt wird sich nicht von
der Welt entziehen können und deswegen
muss man schauen wo geht es noch wo
geht's nicht mehr und da würde ich eben
jetzt anders als sie sagen bei diesem
Hafen Deal das geht noch wenn ich China
jetzt die Bahn kaufen würde mich auch
sofort sagen nie im Leben kriegt er
nicht aber sozusagen müssen wir jetzt
Geschäft für Geschäft Deal für Deal uns
eben genau anschauen und zu schauen was
noch okay ist Frau Löhr also Frage bei
Twitter hat jemand hier am Tisch eine
Zahl was es uns kosten würde uns von
China weniger abhängig zu machen also
eine Zahl mit der kann ich jetzt auch
nicht dienen was bekanntes ist dass
China Deutschlands wichtigster
Handelspartner ist bei den Exporten
liegen die USA an erster Stelle bei den
Importen liegt China an erster Stelle
aber quasi in der Summe import-exporte
ist China mit Abstand wichtigster
Handelspartner Deutschlands dann lassen
Sie mich noch eine Beobachtung sie sind
dran aber weil mir das jetzt in der
Diskussion gerade klar geworden ist also
das eine ist der intensive Handel mit
China unser wichtigster Handelspartner
seit was nicht fünf sechs Jahren das
andere sind chinesische Investitionen in
wichtige kritische interessante Dinge
und Unternehmen bei uns was davon ist
denn das gefährliche
kritischer sind sicherlich die
Beteiligung deswegen wird er ja auch
seit etlichen Jahren schon genauer
hingeguckt also letztlich führen wir die
Debatte ja seit dem Jahr 2016 als der
Roboterhersteller KUKA an einen
chinesischen Konzern verkauft wurde
midea das wurde damals von Sigmar
Gabriel der war Wirtschaftsminister und
Angela Merkel durchgewunken aber danach
gab es dann schon eine recht hitzige
Debatte ob das so gut ist und dann wurde
das Außenwirtschaftsrecht auch mehrfach
verschärft wo eben all diese
prüfschwellen ab wann kontrollieren wir
Beteiligung wann schaut das
Wirtschaftsministerium genauer hin das
wurde dann angezogen deswegen
diskutieren wir jetzt auch über diesen
Fall cosco also ich denke da muss man
auf jeden Fall genauer hinschauen
also genau ich würde den Eindruck teilen
dass wir eine neue also dass wir eine
China Strategie brauchen und ich bin so
ein bisschen skeptisch inwieweit das
dann tatsächlich funktioniert wenn ja
das Kanzleramt offenbar eher gewillt ist
in China freundlichen Kurs von Angela
Merkel Ford zu führen und die Grünen
geführten Ministerien für außen und
Wirtschaft da eher dagegenhalten wollen
von daher bin ich gespannt ob es
tatsächlich eine China Strategie geben
wird die diesen Namen auch verdient wir
haben jetzt analysiert konkretes
Beispiel hafendil
was hat sich in den letzten Jahren
entwickelt mit welchen Abhängigkeiten
und gefahren haben was zu tun
wir haben ja in dieser Zeit mit großen
Worten das Gefühl moment mal man muss
jetzt abbiegen es muss alles anders
werden Wendepunkt Epochenbruch
zeitenwände sind große Worte vielleicht
für den Blick nach vorne was sich ändern
kann soll muss einmal Bundespräsident
Steinmeier diese Woche
ja wir müssen unsere Verwundbarkeit
reduzieren wir müssen einseitige
Abhängigkeiten verringern aber das
bedeutet eben nicht
weniger Vernetzung mit der Welt
sondern das wird Sie überraschen mehr
nicht binden an wenige
sondern Chancen und Risiken streuen sagt
der Bundespräsident Bundeskanzler Scholz
fliegt diese Woche nach China besucht
den Mann sie den Ping der gerade vor
allem Fernsehkameras der Welt
demonstriert hat wie seine Allmacht
weiter gewachsen ist in Brüssel in
Europa gibt es viele die sehr irritiert
sind über diese Reise wie passt dieser
Schritt zur Forderung von Steinmeier
also Klinken für mich nur noch hohl
diese Rede von Herrn Steier Steinmeier
wenn Olaf Scholz im Grunde genau das
Gegenteil praktiziert also es ist
natürlich nicht einzuwenden wenn er das
Gespräch mit China sucht aber wir haben
ja und dann möchte ich diesen Begriff
nicht inflationieren wir haben letzte
Woche noch mal eine Zäsur erlebt und
zwar mit dem Parteikongress in China und
da bin ich mir manchmal nicht so sicher
ob das hier in der Politik schon so
angekommen ist und es bei den
Verantwortlichen
es handelt sich wir
was dort passiert ist auf diesen Partei
das heißt wir hatten vorher mit einer
autoritären Führung zu tun ja aber was
da jetzt passiert ist ist dass wir jetzt
das mit einer knallharten autoritären
Diktatur zu tun haben und wir wissen aus
historischen Gründen wir wissen das
aktuell bei Putin wir wissen das unter
Mao was das immer für gefahren wird wenn
einer nur noch alleine über so ein
großes Land entscheidet und das ist eine
Zäsur in der wir plötzlich jetzt
unmittelbar mit drin stecken und wenn
Scholz jetzt zwei Wochen später als
erster westlicher Regierungschef
überhaupt auf bitten Sie den Pinks was
dann propagandistisch dort auch
entsprechend ausgeschlachtet wird da
dies ein Besuch abstattet dann ist das
das völlig falsche Signal also es gab
Bemühungen von französischer Seite
macron von der EU-Kommission doch da
gewisse Zeichen auch zu setzen
vielleicht so ein Besuch oder so wie
auch immer das gemeinsam zu absolvieren
und eben nicht diese Alleingänge aber
vor allem in der Kombination Scholz mit
DAX Unternehmern das ist das völlig
falsche Signal zu dem was in der letzten
Woche auf diesen Parteikongress passiert
ist dass wir es mit einem brutalen
Diktatur entdiktator jetzt zu tun haben
zum Glück können deutsche Journalisten
Journalisten das Beobachten auch dort
sein sie gehören zu denen die das
Beobachten und berichten werden teilen
Sie die Einschätzung also ich halte das
für problematisch jetzt besser gefunden
wenn er mit macron geflogen wäre ob es
jetzt das falsches Signal ist würde ich
dann nach dem Besuch erst bewerten
wollen wenn man weiß was er da gesagt
hat und so wie die Gespräche verlaufen
sind dann glaube ich ist es ist das der
richtige Zeitpunkt ich meine es ist
natürlich so also ich sag das ja auch
wir müssen genauer hinschauen wir dürfen
nicht mehr mit jedem Geschäfte machen
aber wir sind natürlich auch in der Lage
in der wir jetzt mit einem Land schon
die Geschäfte heruntergefahren haben
nämlich Russland so und dann ist
natürlich ist es immer eine Abwägung
denn all diese Dinge die wir wollen die
sind ja mit ökonomischen Kosten und
Arbeitsplätze in solchen Dingen
verbunden das heißt deswegen glaube ich
dass diese Strategie des Verwundbarkeit
reduzieren nicht eine sein kann von
heute auf morgen also ist natürlich eine
mittelfristige Geschichte und bis wir da
sind und bis wir die neuen Lieferanten
erschlossen haben müssen wir natürlich
unser Zeug irgendwo herkriegen so und
deswegen habe ich ein bisschen
Verständnis dafür zu sagen natürlich
muss eine Regierungschef mit allen
möglichen Leuten reden wichtig ist dann
was er sagt und dass er da nicht zu
Kreuze kriegt
ich halte den Zeitpunkt wirklich für
problematisch da würde ich würde ich dir
bei stimmen denn er ist zu nah am
Parteikongress und er wird als eine Art
internationale Legitimierung ausgelegt
werden in China das hätte klar sein
sollen und ich finde das ist auch wieder
genau ein Zeichen dafür dass macron und
Scholz da gemeinsam sich den besten Weg
vielleicht nach dem G20 Treffen in
Indonesien und vielleicht sogar mit
einem gemeinsamen Besuch auf jeden Fall
abgestimmt hätten machen können dieser
ein Tagestrip hin und zurück
der ist glaube ich das falsche Format es
ist der falsche Zeitpunkt und auf jeden
Fall werden wir als Resultat dessen
nicht erleben dass wir bei seltenen
Erden bei Polo Silicium für für
Solarzellen etc uns diversifizierte
aufstellen das muss woanders herkommen
dafür ist der Besuch der falsche Frage
am See
eine Vorstellung warum gegen die
Argumente die jetzt genannt wurden
dieser Schritt jetzt kommt alleine jetzt
vor dem Gipfel ohne macron nur mit
deutscher Delegation
wenn man es wohlwollend auslegen will
könnte man natürlich auch argumentieren
er reißt dort jetzt hin um auch diese
Allianz zwischen China und Russland die
sich jetzt im Zuge dieses Ukraine Kriegs
herausgebildet hat quasi zumindest zu
versuchen ein wenig zu durchbrechen den
Gesprächsfaden nicht ganz abreißen zu
lassen Chinas inzwischen der wichtigste
Abnehmer für russisches Öl die beiden
Länder haben sich die grenzenlose
Partnerschaft versprochen also das ist
gerade ein recht gefährlicher Zeit wenn
man das ganze weltweite Bild quasi
aufspannt dass da Russland und China ein
Block gegen den Westen bilden und
vielleicht könnte dieser Versuch dazu
dieser Besuch dazu beitragen dass ein
bisschen
aufzubrechen diplomatisch und weniger
wirtschaftlich orientiert
jeder Kanzler der nach China fliegt
fliegt mit einer Wirtschaftsdelegation
dorthin von daher ist das jetzt auch
nicht wirklich überraschend dass es so
kommt aber ich würde in der Tat auch
zustimmen dass die Art und Weise dieser
Zeitpunkt jetzt kurz nach diesem ja doch
sehr denkwürdigen Parteitag ist
problematisch und man muss ja auch immer
gucken was machen also was die Politik
gerne möchte weniger Abhängigkeiten ist
das eine aber die Frage ist ja auch
immer was machen die Unternehmen und da
sind ja gerade also wenn man sich BASF
anguckt Siemens anguckt die denken gar
nicht daran die Abhängigkeiten gegenüber
China zu reduzieren sondern sie weiten
sie eher noch aus also das ist und dann
zu so einem Zeitpunkt mit einer
Wirtschaftsdelegation hinzufliegen ist
dann eben auch aber ein interessanter
Punkt ja also weder die Bundesregierung
noch die EU-Kommission trifft
Entscheidungen für Unternehmen in China
zu investieren oder nicht zu investieren
die China Strategie die die Koalition in
Ihrem Vertrag verabredet hat liegt noch
nicht vor sie ist für das kommende
Frühjahr angekündigt und wenn der jetzt
noch mal konzentr auch die Frage schauen
welcher Weg ist der richtige dann nehme
ich jetzt aus der Diskussion mit also
Steinmeier sagt vernetzen das verstehe
ich so also China halten als Partner
aber viele andere suchen
die Amerikaner nennen ihre Strategie die
kaplängen also die Schneiden einfach
viele Stränge ab die versuchen die
Beziehung zu China deutlich zu
reduzieren es sind zweite Möglichkeit
und ist auch schon erwähnt worden der
Aspekt wir alleine oder wir mit Europa
zusammen also Handy sie haben sicherlich
die perfekte Antwort die china-strategie
wir können Sie hier formulieren weil das
Bundeskabinett noch auf Hinweise wartet
ja und auch online deswegen ist der
Zeitpunkt auch falsch weil diese China
Strategie ja auf Bundesebene aber auch
auf eu-eben den Arbeit ist das kann man
kritisieren dass das eine schnell genug
ist wir brauchen die nämlich ganz
dringend weil in China auch einfach
wahnsinnig viel passiert und China da
ganz konkrete Pläne hat die sie Vorteile
einer autoritärenführung auf viel
schneller umsetzen kann als aber klar in
dieser china-strategie bräuchten wir im
Grunde nicht nur Appelle sondern auch
klare Leitlinien welche Zusammenarbeit
wir eigentlich mit so einer autoritären
Stadt künftig noch haben wollen und
welche nicht und ich würde sagen
kritische Infrastruktur muss außen vor
bleiben darf nicht in die Hand einer
Diktatur geraten ein Unternehmen über
das was Frau Bastian vorhin gesagt hat
also komplett ihr nur bei uns wenn wir
auch bei euch wäre das ja also ich das
wird dir genau
China wird das ja gar nicht zulassen
deswegen wird oder bisschen wäre das ein
Grundsatz also ich höre keinen
Widerspruch am Tisch okay und dann bei
den Unternehmen natürlich jeder ist
Unternehmen das ja der Vorteil einer
freien Marktwirtschaft jedes deutsche
Unternehmen hat soll selbst entscheiden
können wie viel Risiken sie in so einem
Land aufnehmen will wie viel Geschäfte
sie machen will natürlich sollte wäre es
jetzt durchaus auch der Zeitpunkt darauf
hinzuweisen wie groß diese Gefahren sind
das sehen wir am Beispiel Russlands und
die kapling ist ja nicht nur eine
Entscheidung die wir hier alleine fällen
sondern die ja sie hat geopolitische
Zusammenhänge die USA setzen die
Europäer und nicht zuletzt auch die
Deutschen unter Druck und sagen auf
welcher Seite wollte eigentlich künftig
stehen aber China die kappelt ja auch
selber bereits china hat ganz klar den
Plan aufgestellt nach innen autark zu
werden also unabhängig werden auch von
westlicher Technologie und nach außen
Abhängigkeiten zu schaffen und das ist
natürlich eine das ist eine kriegsansage
auch eine wirtschaftspolitisch
kriegsansage und da kann man nicht
hierzulande so tun auch das würde ich
appelliert Latif an die Unternehmer
sagen als könnte man so weitermachen wie
bisher also da muss man da muss man
reagieren da muss man auch glaube ich
strategisch auch durchaus mit der
Politik zusammenarbeiten wie weit man
auf wie man auf so eine Kampfansage
ich bin da gar nicht gegen aber ich
finde wir dürfen nicht nur auf China
gucken was wir machen das uns zum
Problem wenn wir jetzt nur sagen wir
definieren China sondern wir brauchen
insgesamt da fand ich jetzt das Zitat
von Frank-Walter Steinmeier gut wir
brauchen eine diversifiziertere
Ausstellung unserer
ressourcenpolitik zum Beispiel unsere
Außenwirtschaftspolitik denn wenn wir
jetzt zum Beispiel uns zu sehr an die
usa-ketten wir haben in zwei Jahren
Präsidentschaftswahlen wir wissen nicht
ob noch mal Donald Trump oder ein Trump
pista an die Macht kommt das heißt
dieses diversifizierte risikoersere
aufstellen das finde ich es wichtig und
das da gehört China natürlich zu und ist
ganz elementar aber wir dürfen jetzt
auch nicht den Fehler machen dass wir
nach Russland nur auf China schauen
danach alles ausrichten und den Rest
erstmal laufen lassen
ich gebe Ihnen die Frage aus dem Netz
mit wer denn dann China nicht Russland
nicht genau also das Problem ist halt
wenn man nur noch mit seinen Freunden
handeln will dann bleiben irgendwann
ziemlich viele Länder übrig das wird
nicht reichen in Deutschland das heißt
sind wir vielleicht bei Kanada selbst
Frankreich ja wer weiß ob der lepennen
dran kommt Italien haben wir jetzt
gerade gesehen also die Welt ist halt
ständig im Fluss deswegen ist glaube ich
wirklich das Zauberwort dass der diese
Diversifizierung nie in von keinem Land
sozusagen man kann es ja auch vielleicht
irgendwie versuchen numerisch zu
definieren mehr als 5% Abhängigkeit oder
sowas damit eine ausfällt ist zwar
schlimm aber nicht so schlimm jetzt
Russland ja also wir kommen ja irgendwie
klar mit dem Ausfall Russlands wo wir
ziemlich abhängig waren und wenn man
wenn wir uns da breiters streuen dann
ist das ist glaube ich die Lösung und
noch ein anderes
am Ende geht es ja auch wirklich sehr
stark um Ökonomie und wenn wir nicht
sagen unsere Rohstoffe von überall her
kriegen können weil die Länder alle
volatil sind dann muss man auch so Dinge
wie Kreislaufwirtschaft Recycling so
Zeugs glaube ich auch verstärkt
nachdenken damit wir halt nicht zu sehr
abhängig sind von irgendwelchen
Lieferungen sind wir ich glaube wir sind
uns da was das diversifizieren angeht
sehr einig und ich denke auch jetzt der
Weg den die Amerikaner gehen dass eben
autark möglichst autark werden möglichst
viel im eigenen Land produzieren den Weg
in China geht eben auch möglichst autark
werden ich glaube nicht dass das
letztlich die Lösung ist weil unser
Wohlstand der vergangenen Jahrzehnte ist
ja sehr stark davon geprägt worden das
wird von der internationalen
Arbeitsteilung profitiert aber man darf
halt
den Gedanken also weil das genau ja die
Frage ist also gehen wir zurück dahin wo
die Weltwirtschaft vor dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg mal war also die Strategie
hieß ja Wandel durch Handel also es war
die feste Überzeugung dass man durch
Handel Werte teilen kann auch Demokratie
verbreiten kann gut Wandel durch Handel
da war ja immer stand der Wunsch
dahinter dass man dann eben das
vielleicht autokratisch geführte Regime
dann irgendwann auch liberale
Demokratien werden da merken wir jetzt
dass das eher nicht so gut funktioniert
aber nichtsdestotrotz schafft Handel ja
Wohlstand und deswegen muss es unser
elementares Bestreben sein diesen
Wohlstand und diesen freien Handel auch
weiter zuzulassen aber er braucht halt
er muss ergänzt werden um eine
Sicherheitskomponente und ich glaube das
ist jetzt die große Herausforderung dass
wir zum einen definieren müssen in
welchen Bereichen kritische
Infrastruktur bei welchen Rohstoffen
sind wir besonders abhängig und wie
werden wir stellen wir uns da breiter
auf das ist jetzt der entscheidende
Punkt und Land wie Japan zum Beispiel
das ja außenpolitisch eine sehr klare
Kante auch gegenüber China fährt oder
ein klangkurs gegenüber China fährt ist
das schon Schritt weiter die haben jetzt
so einen eine Art gesetzt
wirtschaftssicherheitsgesetz auf den Weg
gebracht wo sie zum Beispiel Unternehmen
belohnen die
Lagerhaltung betreiben was wichtige
Rohstoffe angeht die sich breiter
aufstellen woher beziehen Sie
verschiedene Rohstoffe weil letztlich
ist es teurer wenn man sich breiter
aufstellt aber im Ernstfall hat man dann
auch nicht ganz so viel zu verlieren
wenn man das macht ich denke da
vielleicht noch ein letzter Punkt das
Wirtschaftsministerium von Robert Habeck
ist in den vergangenen Monaten sehr
stark eine Energieministerium gewesen
ein Gas sicherungsministerium gewesen
und ich denke es ist jetzt wirklich
elementar das breiter aufzustellen und
vor allem auch diesen rohstoffpunkt also
Seltene Erden haben wir schon
angesprochen das quasi mit rein zu
nehmen weil wenn wir diese Rohstoffe
nicht haben dann ist auch die ganze
Energie wenn wir wirklich funktionieren
dann kriegen wir keine Solarzellen keine
Windturbinen keine kein Lithium für die
Elektromotoren also das ist
man muss auch im Wirtschaftsministerium
denke ich das Bild breiter spannen also
ich halte fest
die Perspektive das Handel Wohlstand
bringt war zu kurz gegriffen plötzlich
stellt sich die Frage wie viel
Unsicherheit wie viel Risiko da drin
steckt wir haben die verschiedenen
risikoformen besprochen die sich ergeben
aus Enger Verflechtung ein Weg haben sie
gesagt ist ja logisch man selbst auf
mehr Partner und versucht sozusagen
weniger Eier in demselben Korb zu legen
sie haben gesagt ja es wird auch nicht
Autarkie aber schon Elemente geben
müssen wie man schaut wie sind wir im
eigenen Land herstellungsfähig wir haben
wir die Rohstoffe die Dinge die wir
brauchen
geht das alles einher mit freiem Handel
freier Marktwirtschaft sie haben das
Beispiel Japan erwähnt auch die USA
behalten sich ja mittlerweile vor ihren
Unternehmen Investitionen zu verbieten
also kann eine solche Strategie einfach
nur ein Appell an die Wirtschaft sein
oder kommen wir da in eine starke
Steuerung ich glaube China ist deswegen
auch eine Herausforderung weil es eben
einige Teile der Marktwirtschaft
hochgradig in Frage stellen und zwar ist
China sehr erfolgreich gewesen vor allem
Schlüsselindustrien zum die nicht nur zu
definieren sondern gezielt zu fördern
und da haben wir es natürlich dann ab
einem bestimmten Punkt schwer damit zu
halten also
westliche Unternehmen wenn da die
chinesische hinter der chinesischen
Konkurrenz immer ein so starker Start
dahinter steckt für mich stellt sich
dann schon auch die Frage also dass man
nicht nur die kritische Infrastruktur
stützt sondern inwiefern man
industriepolitisch durchaus auch wieder
Schlüsselindustrien stärker definiert
und sie auch konkreter fördert also ich
rede von der Batterietechnologie bei der
rohstoffsuche
im Grunde sämtlichen Technologien die
auch die Energiewende für die
Energiewende notwendig sind auch da sind
wir ja extrem abhängig von chines von
China momentan und ich glaube da kann
man nicht nur da Appellativ sagen okay
Unternehmen kümmert euch mal drum oder
Vorstand mal mehr oder investierter mehr
mal ich glaube da muss auch vom Staat
mehr Förderung oder mehr Unterstützung
kommen und es gibt die Programme das
batterieprogramm zum Beispiel aber da
muss man auch noch mal gucken und
deswegen drücke ich so ein bisschen also
oder hoffe dass es alles auch ein
bisschen schneller geht weil in China
dass ich das so massiv verändert auch
die Diversifizierung also völlig dakor
aber ich glaube es global Gateway wurde
als Antwort der G7 auf die Seitenstraße
gegeben aber wenn ich mir angucke wie
schwerfällig und wie langsam sich das
alles tut da habe ich die Befürchtung
dass da China
uns nicht nur einholt sondern das nicht
mehr einholbar ist und das macht mir
große Sorgen genau ich glaube auf diesem
Weg muss man aber vorsichtig sein dass
wir nicht in einen Staatsdirigismus
kommen sondern dieser dieser Grad der
muss wirklich gut gut gewählt sein wir
werden ganz viel Druck haben wenn wir
uns jetzt anschauen dass die USA zum
Beispiel den Export von Halbleiter von
Halbleitern und der Maschinen zur
Herstellung von Halbleitern ihren
Unternehmen verboten haben da wird auch
der Druck auf Europa kommen dass wir
dass wir uns daran beteiligen und da
müssen wir definieren wollen wir so weit
gehen oder wollen wir nicht so weit
gehen gehört das zu unserer kritischen
Infrastruktur ich glaube es muss zum
Teil dann muss es Subventionen geben die
gibt es ja zum Teil auch da muss man
sich gerade bei den kritischen
Rohstoffen glaube ich muss man in der
Tat das muss man noch mal ausweiten da
wird ja auch gerade dran gearbeitet
diese Abschottung die wir in Teilen
haben werden diese Schutzmauern die wir
hochziehen werden die werden Kosten das
ist jetzt schon so dass der
Internationale Währungsfonds zum
Beispiel davon ausgeht dass die
Inflation steigt eben weil wir diese die
Tendenzen in einzelnen Weltteilen haben
und da müssen wir wirklich vorsichtig
sein wie viel also wirklich nur die
wirklich zentralen Bereiche schützen und
nicht in anderen Bereichen wo uns dieser
Handel wo uns der internationale
Austausch den jemand bringt unnötige
Mauern hochzuziehen und deswegen muss es
da auch ein Konsens in der Regierung
drüber geben ja die
kappling-ligators wörtlich heißt
entwirren abschneiden
deswegen glaube ich auch eben weil
dieser dieser schutzaspekt mit Kosten
verbunden ist also Sachen werden einfach
teurer wenn wir sie nicht mehr billig
aus China kaufen können ich lasse mal
Ökologie aus dem vorher sondern ein
anderes Thema aber Sachen werden teurer
werden und es wird Leute belasten Leute
wenn das spüren aber deswegen ist eben
dass die zweite Komponente sozusagen das
aktive Fördern von Schlüsselindustrien
bei uns in Deutschland und in Europa
genauso wichtig denn das ist ja was was
potenziell Wohlstands fördernd und
Wohlstand steigernd ist also wenn wir
einfach bessere Autos und Batterien und
sowas bauen als die Chinesen und bessere
Solarzellen das haben wir alles komplett
hier abgegeben das ganze Geschäft dann
dann wachsen da auch neue Industrien
heran und dann kann man da dadurch aus
wo auch Wohlstand wieder wieder sichern
deswegen habe ich es schon wir haben es
zu tun mit einer neu Definition des
Staates der die verschiedenen von
sozusagen der Rolle des Staates in
neoliberalen Zeitalter der hypergl
Globalisierung jetzt sagen geht es darum
viel stärker steuernd einzugreifen danke
für diese
kluge Analyse die ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen kann ich hätte dann zum
Schluss noch die Frage wer dann wir oder
der Staat ist ich habe es eben schon mal
angedeutet also sind dass wir die
Bundesrepublik ist das Europa geht das
ohne die USA oder müssen wir das Fest
mit denen abstimmen also wer ist
sozusagen der Kreis derer der sich auf
die Strategie verständigt erstmal muss
es Deutschland sein also und das wird
schon schwer genug da eine gemeinsame
konsenslauer zu finden wie wir an dem
Beispiel cosco gesehen haben aber
letztendlich so weit will ich jetzt
nicht gehen Ich denke schon dass das
aber die Frage ist wird diese Strategie
die sich in der Strategie irgendeinen
Einfluss haben oder werden es warme
Worte auf Papier sein aber das ist kann
nur der erste Schritt sein letztlich
muss die EU als Ganzes mit einer Stimme
auftreten gerade eben weil Amerika
Routine sich zunehmend verfeindet
gegenüberstehen und wenn wir alle unsere
Kraft in Europa in der EU zusammenwerfen
sind wir die zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft
der Erde also es gibt durchaus was was
wir zu bieten haben aber wenn wir das
nicht machen sondern 27 Einzelinteressen
vertreten und die einen mehr mit China
handeln wollen und die anderen weniger
dann werden wir ein Problem haben wer
sind denn wir also ich würde sagen
inzwischen ich habe lange Zeit immer
argumentiert ja Deutschland und Europa
brauchen eine eigenständige
china-strategie angesichts dessen was in
China in welcher Geschwindigkeit das
passiert habe ich die Befürchtung das
reicht nicht mehr aus wir müssen ganz
ganz dringend auch mit den USA im Grunde
mit sämtlichen westlich orientierten
demokratisch marktwirtschaftlich
orientierten Kräften da jetzt an einer
China Strategie Arbeiten zumal wie das
Frau Bastian ja auch darauf hingewiesen
hat in den zwei Jahren schon nicht mehr
wissen was für eine Konstellation wir in
den USA haben also ich habe das Gefühl
die Zeit drängt und es reicht dann eben
nicht mehr aus sich im kleinen hier erst
auf nationaler Ebene da in der
Ampelkoalition da darauf zu warten bis
sie sich auf irgendwas geeinigt hat aber
wie gesagt der größte Fehler ist
natürlich in diesen ganzen Zuge in
diesen ganzen Prozess der jetzt ansteht
und ganz dringend definiert werden muss
das Scholz jetzt auf alleine nach Peking
heißt Frau Bastian das ist zumal also es
ist wir jetzt nur Europa oder zusammen
mit den USA und wir hören Argumente die
dafür und dagegen sprechen ich glaube es
ist sowohl als auch und ich würde die G7
dann noch mal mit ins Spiel bringen weil
ich glaube dass es auf G7 Ebene auf
Initiative der Amerikaner durchaus die
Diskussion geben wird wie man kritische
Technologien wieder wie China schützen
kann das heißt es wird parallel eine
Diskussion auf Europaebene geben und
wenn es es wird schwierig sein die 27 da
unter einen Hut zu kriegen da gibt es
sehr diverse Interessen aber zumindest
müssen sich Frankreich und Deutschland
einig sein und da eben auch auf die EU
einwirken dann wird das parallel den G7
Prozess geben und parallel dazu wird das
auch das Arbeiten an der Deutschen
china-strategie geben Europa also vor
drei oder vier Jahren haben wir darüber
gesprochen dass unsere Abhängigkeit von
den USA zu groß ist als Trump nämlich
Sanktionen verhängt hat das heißt ich
würde es für extrem riskant halten und
dann sitzen wir nämlich in zwei Jahren
da und sprechen riskante Geschäfte in
USA ich würde es für extrem riskant
halten sich da zu sehr auf die
Amerikaner mit ihren eigenen Interessen
zu verlassen
das passt ganz gut zum Ende dieser
Sendung denn wenn sie in der ARD dabei
bleiben dann folgt das europamagazin mit
dem Bericht aus Brüssel eines der Themen
dort ist aber die Lage der Flüchtlinge
in Belgien und den Niederlanden bedanke
mich sehr herzlich für diese ja ich
glaube sehr erklärende Debatte auch die
wir geführt haben und wenn Sie mehr
wollen bleiben Sie dran bei Presseclub
nachgefragt im Radio und bei Phoenix und
natürlich im Netz und ansonsten danke
tschüss und lassen Sie es gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz bei Tagesschau und
presseclub.de im Radio bei WDR 5 und im
Fernsehen bei Phoenix und am Telefon mit
Sandra loisert aus Hamburg hallo Frau
so da ist sie
bin ja ich bin Hamburgerin bin 55 Jahre
alt und ich habe ich finde es natürlich
als Hamburgerin ganz fürchterlich das
Teile des Hamburger Hafens letztlich
da verkauft verscheidet werden sollen
und die Frage die sich
mir stellt ist ich wann also ich meine
dass man irgendwann mal anfangen muss
auch langfristig zu denken ich meine es
sind Kriege darum geführt worden weil
man auch in der Historie braucht man nur
zu gucken
wo es vom logistischen und vom
strategischen Standpunkt hier
die
Hafen also die sie Punkte sind also
Punkte sie sind und nicht das zu sagen
darf und ja und letztlich ist so auch
für mich die Frage langfristig oder
überhaupt grundsätzlich welche Strategie
verfolgen wir wir haben schon dabei als
Piräus durch die Troika mit unserem zu
tun dazu gezwungen worden ist Piräus zu
verscherben wo wollen wir eigentlich hin
Frau Lauser danke dass sie da ihre
Gedanken geäußert haben das ist ja die
Frage die wir der ganzen Sendung steht
wir haben gleich noch eine weitere
Stimme aus Hamburg ich würde sagen das
ist heute angemessen Martin Macker ist
in der Leitung auch von Ihnen gerne eine
Stimme aus Hamburg
einen wunderschönen guten Tag in die
Runde ich bin der Meinung dass wir alle
das Vermögen der unterscheidenden
Intelligenz haben und dazu gehört dass
wir ganz klar ja oder nein sagen können
und wir können auch ganz berechtigt
ungeduldig werden ich war letztens in
einer wartesituation die mich nicht
zufriedengestellt hat und da habe ich
einfach gesagt weil Sie bitte weiterhin
liebenswürdig dann kam die Entgegnung
die bitte auch natürlich dazu habe ich
gar nichts gesagt kann aber schon
alleine zu sagen ja oder nein wir sind
die Grenzen und hier sagen wir ja und da
sagen wir nein weil es gibt letztendlich
immer wir haben eine ganz schlechte
Handyverbindung Leiter leider
was ich sage oder ich glaube ein Teil
des Publikums nicht deshalb können Sie
vielleicht noch mal so in einem Satz zum
Schluss eine Frage oder ihre Positionen
dann versuche ich es noch mal zu
wiederholen damit alle verstehen
ich begrüße den innerhalb eines
demokratischen
entscheidungsmechanismus
stattgefundenen reduzierten Anteil von
Tieren 20,9 man ist auf 35% auf 24,9
innerhalb des demokratischen
Entscheidungsprozesses zurückgegangen
und deswegen liebe ich es in einer
Demokratie zu leben super danke groß
nach Hamburg das haben wir nur kurz
angesprochen diesen Unterschied von 35
geplanten zu weniger als 25 verkauften
Prozent mag kurz jemand einordnen welche
Rolle das spielt es spielt natürlich
insofern eine Rolle dass der Einfluss
Chinas dadurch sinkt also dass sie keine
Sperrminorität haben dass sie kein
Geschäftsführer bestellen können also
faktisch erstmal weniger Einfluss auf
die Geschehnisse an diesem Container
Terminal haben werden ich würde was die
Entscheidungsfindung angeht dann schon
darauf hinweisen wollen dass die sehr
ungewöhnlich ist
zustande ist weil es eben eine sehr
einsame Entscheidung des Kanzlers war
gegen den Rat von sechs Fachministerien
nicht nur Grüne und FDP auch zwei
spd-ministerien waren dagegen gegen den
Rat der EU-Kommission gegen den Rathaus
Verfassungsschutzes also
dass das jetzt quasi Maßgabe für
künftige Entscheidungen so sein sollte
da hätte ich doch Bauchschmerzen wir
sind in Bayern am Chiemsee in Bernau bei
Markus Rossmann guten Tag grüß Gott ja
hallo also ich habe folgende Frage an
den Herrn Lee wie gesagt meine Frau ist
Griechin und ich habe eben auch diese
ganze Sache mit dem piräus-fahrt
mitbekommen die trojka wollte den ja
abwickeln in den krisenmedien war da
immer gestanden die
Konkurrenten Rotterdam und Hamburg
wollten sich eines unliebsamen
Konkurrenten entledigen die Griechen
sind dann auf die Chinesen gesprungen
die haben das sie haben die gesamte
Infrastruktur aufgebaut und es ist ein
hoch
ein hoch effektives wirtschaftlich
gewinnbringendes jobbörner
herausgekommen
interessante Aspekte
machen sollen
danke ja also ich glaube die Griechen
standen ja wirklich massiv unter Druck
da im Zuge der Euro-Krise und da wurde
ja offensiv nicht zuletzt von deutscher
Seite massiv dazu gedrängt dass sie ihre
Silber waren quasi verscherbeln das ist
passiert das Piräus so erfolgreich ist
das überrascht natürlich auch nicht das
hätte man ein Gründe damals auch schon
wissen können weil
teilweise diese Strategien die China
verfolgt auf seinen welthandelswegen
durchaus schon bekannt waren und Piräus
natürlich auch verkehrsgünstig liegt
also im östlichen Mittelmeerraum also
all das hätte man wissen können zumal
China also mit cosco halt einen ein sehr
sehr extrem starker finanzkräftiger
Staatsunternehmen dahinter steckt also
all diese Punkte überraschen jetzt nicht
also dass die jetzt auch noch profitabel
sind und da kann man durchaus auch das
geschickte geschäftsbahn von durchaus
auch hervorheben
hat natürlich aber zugleich auch die
Konsequenz das und so was passiert
inzwischen schon wenn China dann sagt
oder cosco sagt wir wollen hier keine
taiwanischen Schiffe zum Beispiel
anlaufen lassen dann passiert das auch
und das ist genau der politische Preis
den Europa dafür gezahlt hat quasi
Piräus an China zu verscherben danke
schön ihr Lieben Herr Rossmann danke
aber sie haben das noch mal gut
zugespitzt danke für den Anruf
Essen im Ruhrgebiet Paul Fleck am
Telefon hallo ja hallo schönen guten Tag
ich habe eine Frage alle so erstmal
allgemein eins Punkt eins können wir
einen Kanzler uns erlauben der sich
nicht daran erinnern kann was vor zwei
Jahren passiert ist wegen
cumex-affären offiziell zu sagen ich
kann mich nie dran erinnern erstens
zweitens für sechs Ministerien darunter
auch unsere interne in Klammern CIA sagt
bitte nicht der sagt doch bum 25%
-0,1 verkaufen wir weil ich eventuell
davon profitieren kann oder was weiß ich
vielleicht hat er versprochen dass alles
früher aber ist das die Demokratie
sind 6 Ministerien jedes Ministerium hat
mindestens 2000 arbeitet nehmen und die
sagen alle nein bitte nicht das ist
gefährlich ne egal mache ich ja also
nach zwei Jahren später sagt er wieder
ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern ja
aber ihre Frage war ja zugespitzt also
ist das demokratie heißt ja demokratie
heißt jeder entscheidet in unserem Land
mit 82 Millionen jeder Partei und
beziehungsweise zumindestens Hamburg
Leute die da Leben Hamburger sollen das
entscheiden und nicht unser Kanzler
also Hamburger die Hamburger waren ja
dafür der Hamburger Regierungschef Peter
Tschentscher ist ja für den Verkauf
gewesen
Demokratie formal ist natürlich
Demokratie der die Regierung hat
entschieden es gibt ein
Kabinettsbeschluss die Ministerien haben
sich haben sie Protokoll gegeben das ist
nicht gut finden aber trotzdem mit
seinen ist es seinen formal korrekten
Gang gegangen ist es auch inhaltlich
demokratisch das ist so die Frage also
wenn der Konflikt zu groß wird dann
muss halt einer der beiden
konditionspartner sagen nee okay das ist
jetzt nicht bei uns Regierung da sind
wir nicht mehr dabei das ist nicht das
wofür wir gewählt werden das ist glaube
ich einfach dann der
Korrekturmechanismus das glaube ich
konnte jetzt verhindert werden durch
diese Reduzierung des prozentanteils
aber ansonsten
bald sie wieder Wahlen ja da kann man
dann Olaf Scholz noch mal wählen oder
man kann ihn abwählen Rainer Nickel in
Bremen ist am Telefon sie sind dran
hallo ich wünsche ihnen alles schönen
Sonntag ich habe eine Anmerkung dazu zu
der Sache sie haben gesagt mit dir kann
konnte Koka übernehmen aber deutsche
Anleger dürfen keine Mini erkennen keine
medial Aktien kaufen also der verkaufte
Kapitalmarkt hat ja gar nicht diese
Freiheiten wenn wir von einer freien
Wirtschaft sprechen und der Staat hier
in Deutschland dass er mit Juniper macht
verhält sich da auch nicht anders als
das was du etwa die Chinesen befürchtet
wird der nimmt da auch Einfluss hat die
erst gezogen Gas zu kaufen finanziell
passen die ruinengewirtschaftet und
jetzt will er das für sie nicht Geld
will als feuchte nicht das Übernehmen
der eine doch nicht anders und da gibt
es viele Beispiele da gibt es den
Kurzzeit hier in Bremen der auch nur mal
wenn irgendein Konkurs sind oder
finanziell am Abgrund stehen da werden
einsteigt und ein bisschen
Schnäppchenpreis übernimmt klare ist
angekommen und merke dass Frau Bastian
schon bin ich sagen brodelt aber
nachdenkt brodelt
Nickel das ist
doch dazwischen gibt dass Deutschland in
so einer Krise jetzt einen Konzern wie
Juniper rettet gezwungen haben sie
Juniper ja auch nicht unbedingt das Gas
einzukaufen das würde ich auch nicht
teilen aber so eine staatsrettung die
kann man diskutieren kann man sehr wohl
diskutieren kann man auch kritisch sehen
finde ich aber anders in China ist eben
dass sie da
Staatskonzerne haben die wirklich
gepampert vom Staat in Zukunftsbranchen
gehen und auch das internationale Feld
quasi damit zum Teil überrollen das ist
schon ein bisschen anders als eine
staatsrettung die wir hier in
Deutschland haben würde ich sagen Danke
für den Austausch Argument gegen
Argument hennickel Wünsche was
ja ich bin Aktionär von uniper ich weiß
was er läuft danke schön okay schönen
Sonntag
gesternshausen liegt in Bayern und dort
lebt Raimund Perl unter uns angerufen
hallo Herr Hallo ich bin auf Sendung
total absolut live gut dann mal nur ganz
unspezifisch in den Raum geworfen wo
fährt der Transrapid jetzt habe ich
jedenfalls bei mir ums Eck rum einen
Weltmarktführer in Sachen
Industrierobotik namens Coca und da ist
China vor ein paar Jahren mit einem
absolut minimalen Anteil also ein
irgendwie einstellige Prozentzahl
eingestiegen
aber irgendwie ist geschafft
mittlerweile die Mehrheit über den Laden
zu erreichen und es beginnt der
komplette technologische Ausverkauf das
heißt also gucke ist eigentlich nicht
mehr als barrierehöhle die technologisch
wäre damit
nun frage ich
Lee oder den gewährs machen von der von
der Zeit ja wie will man das beim
Hamburger Hafen verhindert der ist
nämlich auch eben halt im Prinzip
logistischer
Weltmarktführer mit also mit Teilnehmer
ja danke Frage ist angekommen sie werden
jetzt von Herrn Lee oder Herrn schieritz
unterschiedliche Antworten bekommen
deshalb sagen Sie mir bitte wer
Antworten soll
mir egal wer sich berufen erfüllt
naja also die Frage war jetzt wie man
verhindern kann dass China noch mehr in
den Hafen einsteigt also ja da gibt es
natürlich klare Regeln und wenn das wenn
das die deutsche Seite nicht will dann
kann man das auch weiter verhindern
aber die Frage ist ja wird das denn
politisch dann so auch erkannt ob das
dass es eben nicht dann doch zu noch
mehr Beteiligung gibt und die gibt kommt
und die
länger gehenden gefahren und das sehen
wir ja dass das jetzt die gesamten
nordministerpräsidenten haben sich ja
für den Verkauf ausgesprochen und dann
sieht man natürlich sie denken lokal
da profitieren die wirtschaftlich von
aber haben eben dieses geopolitische
diese geopolitische weit sich dann nicht
mit einbezogen das würde ich den jetzt
mal unterstellen und das ist natürlich
das darf sich wiederholen meinen diese
Befürchtung ist da und deswegen finde
ich es halt so wichtig dass wir da jetzt
auch ganz klare Leitplanken brauchen wie
wir auch als Gesamtes Land oder als
Gesamtes Europa oder die westliche Welt
mit China umgehen damit das damit es zu
solchen zu solchen Unwissen
entscheidendung nicht kommt Herr
scheritz wir haben noch 20 Sekunden
haben sie was hinzuzufügen oder zu
widersprechen nein ist genauso ich hätte
ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen in die
Möglichkeit der Politik zu erkennen und
dann doch nein zu sagen wenn Sie mehr
wollen aber das ist
wird man erst sehen wenn es soweit ist
dann bedanke ich mich Herr Perl haben
sie sogar zwei Antworten
und ein gedenktes Mahnmals wo fährt der
okay danke Gruß nach Bayern und ihnen ja
Gruß in einen sonnigen spät Oktober
Sonntag genießen Sie den Rest davon
danke dass Sie dabei waren tschüss und
lassen Sie es gut gehen
gesellschaftlicher Frieden und
Stabilität sind in Gefahr wegen
Inflation gasknappheit drohender
Rezession Krise ist wie so schön heißt
die Stunde der Exekutive der Regierung
und die nimmt die